once upon a few weeks ago abby's tore  through grid iron Heights  word has it this monster can run for  2,000 yards on any pair you want any  some say at night he'll jump the phones  right out of your body  but scariest of all he's only a rookie  aah  have you guys seen my pants tell me once  how come in to dress up a kid a cup Andy  Dalton  it's a blast Oh joganki I love ring  class good because it's the only ring  you'll be getting while I'm still in the  lead  look Ryan Fitzpatrick is handing out  candy stay there guys  I'll get you candy apple full-size  chocolate bar okay third down let's get  this house why because of that creepy  clown no that's wrong terrific blows OH